Sur les réseaux sociaux,
nous sommes habitués à voir des vidéos d'adorables
animaux. Mais derrière ces images mignonnes se cache 1
réalité bien sombre,
des animaux maltraités,
entassés sans aucun égard pour leur bien-être.
Pourtant, tu as le pouvoir de changer cette situation
et je vais te montrer comment.
Le neuf/06 auront lu les élections européennes,
les citoyennes et les citoyens
européens vont élire leurs
représentants pour les prochaines années à venir.
Pour voter, il faut avoir au -18 ans et être inscrit
sur les listes électorales.
Tu peux vérifier sur le site internet du
gouvernement si tu es déjà inscrit.
Attention,
tu vas jusqu'au 3 mai pour réaliser cette inscription.
Si tu souhaites faire
changer les choses et améliorer la
condition animale,
le neuf/06, vote pour le parti animaliste !